this scheme that was done this child sex
trafficking thing this is where I think
a lot of the conspiracy theorists get
lost right all the conspiracy theorists
they go oh Hollywood is a bunch of
pedophiles and politicians and global
eats they're a bunch of pedophiles and
all this kind of [ __ ] I honestly believe
it's not that they're all pedophiles
it's this is the thing that they use to
compromise people to maintain power over
them and control over them this is what
they use now in the past it was maybe
being gay right like you catch someone
doing some gay [ __ ] and then you go eh
we're gonna out you as gay and now it's
okay to be gay so okay you could help me
as gay and I can get a bunch of PC
points and I'll be okay right
before maybe there was a time where they
just killed people flat out right now
we're at a time where I you cannot think
of anything more horrible than [ __ ]
kids
it's absolutely disgusting and that's
what they use and I think they're using
as a power and their power tool and I
think that these people who are part of
generational spy families right general
let's say William bar is part of it we
don't know and his dad put up suit that
means that's two generations as well
it's not just Gillen Maxwell I don't
know if William Baris but let's say his
dad Donald was tied in right and now
William is also tied in that's two
generations this is not some like old
random people are doing a sex
trafficking ring this is how do we
compromise people in positions of power
and manipulate them to get what we want
out of the taboo of pedophilia exactly
and I think these cosmetics had a philia
okay if we became okay with it like
people okay with homosexuality then
they'd have to find something oh my god
the Romans in the whole empire just oh
that's right once guys found it was okay
to [ __ ] guys I deal with these [ __ ]
anymore deal with this [ __ ] all the time
bleeding all over the [ __ ] place
little trickle blood comes out an
[ __ ]
you clean that up that's why we embed
diplomas anyway point is I think these
conspiracy theorists crazy I think that
they lose a lot of the common folk when
they start going everybody in all he was
a pedophile right that's where they lose
the common folk in my opinion I think if
they said they are using pedophilia and
they're using child sex trafficking as a
tool they themselves could no it's awful
and that's why they're using it because
of how awful it is does that match up
mark can I ask you guys a question yeah
this is not to say that there aren't
pedophiles that are like Prince Andrew
is probably a pedophile and they know
that he is so they're targeting him
specifically because they know that they
can compromise him and by compromising
him the royal family has to protect
itself the royal family is an entity and
of itself right so if any one of those
people look like they doing some foul
[ __ ] the royal family got to cover that
up because that bleeds into the rest of
the family and then once the royal
family covers up one person gotcha [ __ ]
same with epstein too like he's a
pedophile but they're able to use his
pedophilia predisposition as a ability a
tool to control him mm-hmm
we all saw Princess Diana she wasn't
toeing the line took her eyes up out of
here
globally power positions lend yourselves
to beam so that's a very behavior so
that's your answer right there when you
asked why would they do it why would
they beat you can't get me to [ __ ] a
twelve-year-old kid right right maybe
there is a slightly higher correlation
between people who are into pedophilia
and into positions of power because they
view that relationship with the kid as a
position of power not as it's completely
sexualized mm-hmm does that make sense
yeah that's a theory I think the other
direction is also like a possibility
what's that that like if you have power
and you recognize that like American
media and American entertainment it's
like one of the most powerful exports
that America has and that like through
film and music we're actually able to
dominate on a global scale like how the
rest of the world operates like you have
like black lives matter protests
happening all over the world because in
America it's happening you have it
happening in places where there are no
black people yeah and it's because like
America's cultural export is soap-like
prominence so dominant globally and so
why would you give the people that are
able to control and that are the faces
of this cultural export without any sort
of tether to control what they're doing
so this is really interesting you're
let's say you're a kingmaker you're an
exec right you've exported this type of
culture forever you're exhausted bro you
can't keep putting up all these [ __ ]
different you can't put out all these
different ideas and continue to export
this culture you need to take a break
you need to relax you have a [ __ ]
yacht you want to chill out so you want
someone else to continue to do your
bidding
how do you ensure that they're gonna do
what you want them to do you make sure
their compromisable from Prussia Trump
right if that is true that type of [ __ ]
yeah right so how do you ensure that
they'll do the exact thing that you want
to do you need to have some dirt on that
and then the second they try to go
offline you go yo remember remember you
did that foul [ __ ] to that little kid
that's what Scientologists do don't they
maybe they make you confess to like
everything you've ever done and then if
you try to leave they hold that over
your Oh everything you've ever done
priests like in a Catholic Church you
have confession and like you go confess
your sins and you got absolved and
Scientology do the same thing but they
record it it's recorded and if you try
to dip they're like oh well you know you
need help for this thing that you did
that we have on record there's a
documentary going clear it's [ __ ]
wild but the idea could easily be
transferred into other so if they need
to tether powerful people basically you
have the option of give the keys to
someone that's broken that's then
manipulatable and that's someone that is
predisposed to be a pedophile that you
give power or the inverse where you
break them and then give them the keys
yeah either way you need to make sure
they're terrible yeah some would say
that's the speculative conspiracy part
let's let's look obviously we're [ __ ]
around obviously we're you know we're
just talking we don't know every single
fact here right and this is flagrant to
we're not the news we don't have to know
every single fact we're talking about
facts oh yeah I know [ __ ] we made all
this up nothing's real yeah
seven Native Americans hypothesis [ __ ]
is that name one of them bogan is
hypothesis and Pythagoras
[Laughter]
[Applause]